good health day to him and
jaramillo police are investigating a shooting that
happened on tuesday involving the
death of a married couple near the
leigh area i am writing to wiiware according to
detectives they believe this incident
is a homicide suicide
the other low shooting  Today
, the investigation was registered in Norte Las Espigas
near Martin Luther King Iker streets and
on Tuesday in this incident, detectives
say that a man was shot and died
while a woman suffered injuries.
Until now, officials say they do not
know what caused the  shooting
but they do not believe it was random
and if you are looking to buy a house in las vegas' you
will pay more than in previous months
since real estate values ​​continue to rise
according to the latest
report published by real estate
agents in las vegas' of the average price in the
The month of September registered more than 406
thousand dollars for a house, an increase of
20% more compared to last year,
while the price of a condominium  nio or
department registered a record figure at
230 thousand dollars last month now
we pass with your weather
forecast a sunny day with temperatures
in the low 80s is expected to end the week
there will be another chance of rain and
temperatures in the 70s good day
sal y jaramillo greets with his brief
informative for the news now in Spanish
[Music]